[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a british psychological
thriller film called exam
spoilers ahead watch out and take
care at the beginning of the movie eight
candidates are shown getting ready for a
hiring examination for a profitable
corporate job some candidates motivate
themselves with encouraging words while
some add a few touch-ups to their
appearances before moving to the
examination hall the place is dimly lit
with desks for every candidate kept
uniformly throughout the room it also
has cameras to monitor their activities
after the eight of them are seated a
guard with a gun enters the room visibly
making the candidates nervous he is
followed by a man who doesn't tell them
his name and simply introduces himself
as the invigilator he then apologizes to
them for the hardships they have faced
to reach this room revealing that the
candidates have passed all the previous
hiring processes and are the finalists
if they pass this last test they will be
getting the job of their dreams as the
rule of this test the invigilator claims
that no federal law applies inside the
examination hall and the candidates are
supposed to follow only the law of the
exam they are not allowed to communicate
with the guard or the invigilator
similarly if they ruin the paper
intentionally or accidentally and if
they walk out of the room for any reason
they will be disqualified the candidate
will have 80 minutes to complete the
test there is only one question on the
paper before them that they need to
answer the invigilator then asks them if
they have any questions when no one
answers he wishes them luck starts the
timer and walks out the candidates turn
their respective papers around and see
that it is completely blank all of them
look at each other in confusion as time
passes they become more nervous hence
candidate number two starts writing on
her paper why she thinks she is eligible
for the job the camera in the room zooms
into her paper and the guard is told to
throw her out because she ruined her
paper number two begs for a second
chance as the guard locks the doors on
her a while later number five realizes
that the rule says they cannot talk to
the invigilator and the guard which
means they can talk to each other he
tells the others the same thing making
them believe that they will have to work
together to find what the question is
before they can answer it the group
discusses several ways they can pass the
test but all of them are just as
confused this is just like real exams
throughout this candidate number one
doesn't speak at all one man tries to
introduce himself but number five
suggests they give each other pet names
so they wouldn't have to reveal their
true identity he goes on to name
candidate number one def because he
hasn't spoken yet then the guys are
named brown black and white according to
their race and the girls are named
blonde brunette and dark according to
their hair color after that white
suggests they get up from their seats
because there is no rule that says they
cannot he takes a chance and gets up to
everyone's delight the guard stays put
meaning that they can move around freely
brunette believes that the questions are
written down on paper with invisible ink
or a watermark they all agree to test
the theory but do not know how to
brunette gets up and uses the lights in
the room to see if something is written
on the paper however nothing is visible
she still insists everyone check their
own because the question could be in
just one of them everyone does as she
says except for deaf who stays quietly
in his seat white takes his paper and
checks it in the light when they do not
get any results black suggests the
writings might be visible in uv rays or
x-rays the group then starts looking for
a switchboard to see if there is any
option to turn on other kinds of lights
when they do not find one they start to
look for the source of such light
themselves def doesn't help them
whatsoever and nervously stays in his
seat blonde finds strips of emergency
lights in the room but since there are
no switches the group has to break all
the other light bulbs to create an
emergency and trigger the lights brown
retaliates saying that they cannot take
such a risk so they vote on the matter
and eventually decide to go forth with
the plan after breaking all the light
bulbs in the room it suddenly glows blue
because of the emergency blacklight
everyone starts to look for the question
in the paper except for deaf but they
are disappointed again because they
cannot see the question brunette asks
everyone to remove the first layer of
the strip light because they aren't lit
this might give rise to uv rays which
can help them they use the woman's heels
to break the strips and reveal another
form of light however they are again met
with disappointment because these lights
do not work either now the group only
has 60 minutes left a frustrated white
asks everyone to think of alternatives
as they brainstorm ideas white registers
that they can do anything to number
two's paper since she is already
disqualified so they gather around her
desk and try tracing the paper with a
pencil still no question comes forth
white then tears her paper into sections
so that they can use them to experiment
with different methods next he pees on
one of the papers to see if it is liquid
activated however that doesn't work
either black and white get into a heated
argument while discussing what they
should do next but they stop after
hearing deaf cry he sob silently in his
seat while the others watch him in
amusement after that the man starts to
blabber in french he asks them if they
can see something in the paper and
claims that the paper reflects their
image they do not think much about his
blabberings and get back into discussing
ideas everyone falls dead silent when
brown speaks he proposes a theory of his
own claiming that they are not in an
exam but are in some kind of betting
show the board members of the company
have placed bets on who will crack under
pressure and the sole purpose of them
being there is for their entertainment
brown has been watching squid game
bruneck thinks that the board members
probably have better things to do with
their time but according to brown money
is the least of their concerns with the
amount of money they have in their life
the board members probably live for the
risks now everyone comes forward with
their own ideas some claim that the
invigilator might be behind this while
others say it might be the ceo they
begin to crack under pressure and insult
each other dar confidently says that
there are no people watching them
because the ceo is hands-on in the
company he has all of the company's
rights and power over everyone it is
clear that she knows more about the
company than anyone else brown asks her
how she knows so much about the ceo it
turns out that dark is already working
for the company in hr but has never seen
the ceo she applied for a higher job and
now she is here white then reveals that
he was headhunted and offered the job
but the others say that they applied for
it however one thing they have in common
is that they do not know anything about
the company or what it does because they
were told not to ask any questions dark
then explains that they are applying for
a famous multi-million dollar
pharmaceutical company called b-rog a
few years ago when a pandemic spread
among young people of the world they
were the first ones to find the cure
currently their yearly turnover is 20
billion dollars all because of their ceo
suddenly black suggests that the company
might have found a cure to the newest
deadly disease that has been killing
millions of people around the world
brunette is suddenly intrigued and asks
dark more about it this makes white
suspicious so he asks brunette if she is
also infected by the virus brunette says
she isn't and dismisses the matter to
take the attention off of herself she
approaches the guard and brings a
lighter out of his pocket without
talking to him then she glances at the
fire alarm the group plans to use the
lighter to trigger the sprinkler because
water can potentially develop the
writing on the paper for this brunette
gets on top of a chair but doesn't reach
the fire alarm white helps her by giving
her a rolled up piece of paper that she
lights up and uses to trigger the alarm
soon water starts showering but the
papers stay the same suddenly the guard
makes his way to the group right then
brunette unfolds the paper in her hand
and reveals it to be her own white had
betrayed her to loosen the competition
the guard drags brunette away as she
calls white a bastard following that an
enraged black says he will punch white's
lights out this makes the lights go out
and the group figures they are voice
activated they ask each other to be
careful with what they say when death
starts to cry again white slyly sits in
front of him and bullies the poor guy
into tearing his own paper and eating it
the guard approaches death and sends him
away as well now only five of the
candidates are left black belittles
white for being an awful person but
white insists they should thank him for
getting their competitors out he also
claims that he knows what the question
is but refuses to tell the others in a
fit of rage black knocks him out with a
single punch the group then ties him to
a seat and covers his mouth with a tie a
while later white gains consciousness
dark removes his gag and he asks for his
medication saying that he is also
infected with the virus and has to take
medicine every hour for him to live
black searches for pills in his pocket
but doesn't find one this makes the
group believe that white is just making
excuses so they will free him however
white claims that one of them has taken
the pill and promises to tell them what
the question is if they give it back
soon he loses consciousness again and
starts to tremble some believe he is
faking but black says he is having a
seizure because of the virus they start
looking for the pill he was talking
about but cannot find it in the room
with only 15 minutes left on the timer
they check each other for the pill dark
suspects brown for taking it and is
proven right when she finds the pill
stuck to some chewing gum under his
table she tries to feed it to white but
brown throws it in a vent as the others
try to get it out a stressed dark goes
in front of the camera and asks the
invigilator to save the man but since
she talked to the invigilator she is
immediately disqualified after she is
gone blonde brings the pill out with a
bobby pin and saves white's life she
also unties him in the process after he
recovers everyone asks him for the
answer he promised white reveals that
the answers are the candidates
themselves they have been searching for
a question all this time but white
thinks that there is no answer and the
one who is left at the end is the answer
the rest of them believe him but before
they can act white runs to get the gun
from the guard black pushes him aside
and acquires the gun himself he points
it at white who confidently claims that
he won't shoot anyone simultaneously he
attacks black and gets the gun however
when he is about to use it he realizes
the gun has fingerprint recognition so
white uses the guard and points the gun
at the others he threatens everyone to
get out of the room on their own so he
can win the position brown doesn't
retaliate with the fear of being shot
and deliberately walks out a scared
blonde slowly walks outside but yells
lights out at the end the room goes
pitch dark making white shoot in random
directions when the lights come back
black falls a limp on the floor with a
bullet hole in his chest white looks
around and sees blonde still has a foot
inside the room he is about to shoot her
as well but notices that the timer has
stopped now white walks to the camera
and tells the invigilator that he is the
winner of the competition the guard
approaches him and shows him the time
white is in shock to see they still have
20 seconds left meaning that he is
disqualified for talking to the
invigilator it is then revealed that def
had changed the time while they were
busy discussing other things at last the
only one left is blonde she walks into
the room and picks up def's glasses that
had fallen while he was being taken out
using those she looks at the paper and
sees question 1 written on it to her
utmost surprise def enters the room
revealing that he is the ceo of the
company and was in the test to keep an
eye on everyone blonde walks up to him
and says no the ceo and the invigilator
smile seeing that she has figured out
the question and passed the test it
turns out when the invigilator asked
them if they had any questions at the
beginning of the test it was the only
question they had to answer the whole
exam was set to test the candidate's
intelligence and attentiveness they hire
blonde as the ceo's secretary but she
doesn't accept the job because she
doesn't want to work with an
organization that kills people the
invigilator reveals that black isn't
really dead and that the bullet he got
hit with is a capsule that heals the
wound after penetrating the body it is
actually the magical medicine they have
recently manufactured which can cure any
disease in the world at last blonde
accepts the job and the movie ends as
she shakes hands with the ceo subscribe
for more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching